this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
Kevin's people were in full force this
week there's a reporter on the TV news
named Charlo Greene if you saw her or
not in in Alaska she she did a story on
the local news where she did a story
about a cannabis club in in Alaska and
apparently in Alaska it's still quite
illegal to smoke and purchase pot oh my
god like where would you want weed more
than where would you need it more you
wake up you're like where the [ __ ] are
we it's still night who cares so she did
a story on the news about this cannabis
club and then at the end of the report
she revealed that she was the owner of
the cannabis club oh really it was like
an M night Shyamalan movie only good did
somebody hit her with water and she
melted yes she was making crop circles
in the cannabis in the cannabis fields
did it turn out they weren't in
old-timey days but really in the present
that's right so then she quit on camera
because she didn't disclose that she was
the owner of this club when she did the
story but she did a story about
something that she was actually the
owner of and then instantly quit and
it's on the air live did anyone say hey
you better quit is she just like well
you can't do that's like that's a big
journalistic no no you can't report on
somebody that you're obviously connected
with there would be a what they call
that day yeah conflict of interest yes
thank you so she had to quit after
having reported on this story but she's
such an advocate of pro marijuana use in
Alaska that she did it anyway to try to
get the conversation going god but it
was the way she quit live on the air
which I was very impressed by so I
brought it in for you all to watch
tonight if you have a nice day the
actual owner of the Alaska cannabis club
will be dedicating all of my energy
toward fighting for freedom and fairness
which begins with legalizing marijuana
here in Alaska and I spread this job
well not that I have a choice but [ __ ]
it oh great
Oh watch our we apologize for that he'll
be we'll be right back me a pardon for
us
meanwhile the boat yes yeah she said
[ __ ] it I quit and walked off the stage
that is [ __ ] spectacular it is pretty
cool that is [ __ ] tacular it is [ __ ]
tacular yeah
wow man nobody [ __ ] like said
anything to her they weren't like hey
you shouldn't do that she was like [ __ ]
it I quit she was like you know what I
quit no she was she had planned the
whole thing she was gonna do the story
then expose that she was the owner of
the story of the business she did the
story about and then quit live on the
air as sort of a big publicity grab once
couldn't she get fined by the FCC for
saying [ __ ] I think she could but she
would just sell some more dope I guess
and pay the fine
[Music]
you
[Music]